[Music]
in flab to fab news submitted by heart
eyes emoji
heart Isaac Isaac you don't wanna be a
hard-ass hard Isaac what do you want to
be like soft oh yeah I saw the other day
oh my god oh it's so cute fearful I'll
change his diaper
he had a boner cuz I really catch them
with boners in you caught him with a
boner once he had a boner and I didn't
know if it was because the diaper molded
his dick that way or if it was actual I
don't know I think I squeeze it like
this he goes oh because I'm like I don't
know how it works I don't want to press
it like this it isn't gonna hurt him I
know he's baby but yeah I'm just like
okay I'm gonna make give you some room
food like I says no I like I says yes
though thank you I've seen that bull
crap the back of his head like seven
times in one day
I think does it again and again I might
stop to welcome us to attain all right a
bald dumpy man becomes a competitive
bodybuilder oh that could be me his wife
suddenly leaves him that's all you need
some motivation never gonna leave me son
yeah I'm too nice yes I want to see this
transformation s die out so this
heartbroken middle-aged Japanese man old
Japanese everyone kept sending me this
guy and saying this is you which one the
before the after they see what she's
Harry the [ __ ] are you talking about
dude
Oh cuz these men I think it's just cuz
he's Japanese only reason hey this is
you
you are Japanese people saying that's
you no no of course not
all right so this guy here he so after
his wife left him for being a bald dumpy
middle-aged guy Ken Watanabe is bald and
he's sexy it looked like this guy all
right
this guy looks huge he's your typical
like dumpy guy's dad oh yeah
goofy fat - oh that's wholesome he looks
like a like a cute little dad yeah yeah
like a supportive father but he gets
[ __ ] ripped and he became black jack
you ain't even that bad what is she
talking about
I thought he had like a red mohawk I
thought he was gonna look way worse than
yeah he looks he looks fine damn yeah he
looks are there pictures of the wife
that left him Oh a dad son no well
housing hello young man
why does it look like your old roommate
oh it's like a two-year transformation
and he's winning [ __ ] Danny trained his
ass off for the highest you've gotten
his fourth place anyway you sure that's
not an Asian window it's not Asian win
that's the Asian four times loss 10th
place in 4th place yeah that's a long
time spore dude you suck yeah you
trained his ass off for two years that's
a lot of motivation that's two years
that's just a two-year in-between but he
looked worse than that yeah that's
amazing oh there's another picture of
him like in a polo shirt and it's like
all sweaty and he's like he's kind of
like scrunched over and stuffing a
yellow stripe I think so dude if I ever
looked like that that means I have to
quit eating everything I like that's
what he did oh what a idiot dude and
it's so hard lost a wife hand food
that's the picture I saw that's
discipline right there that's amazing
though you look like you got way younger
too yeah I mean that's what being fit
does to you huh
and the guy
right looks like he has rock hard
erections - he looks like it's ready to
bus I wonder what he did I need to give
steroids of stand ten push-ups every day
in order for him to keep himself set on
his fitness goals he signed up for a
bodybuilding contest and so he worked
out distantly in the gym keep himself
accountable to keep himself accountable
yeah so I'm working out tomorrow dude
I'm left at 7:00 or lift first
absolutely do maybe insistently places
in the top ten but like I said his his
best finish is winning fourth place in
the Tokyo open bodybuilding tournament
over 40 years old division what the [ __ ]
did the other people look like you it's
amazing fort wait how old is he again
they don't tell me wow he's over 40 he
could be 41 so he changed in his 40s
maybe that's really good that's really
good I'm already sword yeah who's fat
again oh I bet you got a [ __ ]
Japanese girl with a badass
- so now you're the girlfriend and damn
good for him dude cuz they understand
each other's life now yeah they do and
they both don't eat anymore
[Music]
even in Japan if you just eat sushi and
fish all day though I don't think that's
like people's main staple though dude no
they eat a lot of carbs and rice but the
food quality food quality hopes for sure
Japanese food there's just some meals
where it's just good on ya there's
nothing else on it so he says he lives
by the motto which is a Japanese song
lirik what I said that my family
oh the thing is if you want to be reborn
do it while you're still alive that's
that is a really good model dude can you
imagine how toxic is relationship some
barbell stuff inspired that drastic of a
change like if you want to born yet do
it while you're alive okay that makes
sense if you want to be reborn do it
while you're still alive you know those
mean things that his ex-wife said that
was the catalyst so he has a lot to
think because if someone called you fat
and and whatever and then you end up
losing weight it's like well you kind of
owe it to that person who said that [ __ ]
to you too but he also put those yeah I
mean it wasn't solely there but that was
what set it off
I wouldn't say that I guess I see what
you're saying it's like of course it's
not solely dependent on that one person
just like worship sir yeah but very
weird saying because that's kind of I
agree it's so weird because then I guess
Batman would have to thank the guy who
killed his parents right that's probably
she's saying about him welcome you
should thank me
yeah it's the catalyst but I think the
work that people put in is upon
themselves no I'm not discrediting the
work at all yeah so weird it's just use
my bluest right now that's all yeah
because it's like this right without
without without sadness there's no
happiness that's really you can't just
have one it doesn't work that way
I don't ever want to think it's
codependent is what I'm saying it has to
both exist if he teaches that [ __ ] that
would be way funnier so you can't get
this buff without a wife like mine won't
even try it
it ain't about working out it's about
marriage if he just gets even buffer
would be like what are you doing to him
why'd you do this in a mom and guess
what I think thanks for this turning
into this I feel like that works for you
though you work with negative
reinforcement money came with you called
you a piece of [ __ ] because you're not
working out every day you're like what
the [ __ ] dude boom you just start going
at all
then he'll return it to me thinking
that's our communication and I'm like no
no my own negative reinforcement though
I don't really care about what other
people say about me it's like if I have
my [ __ ] in the gym and I leave and I'm
like [ __ ] I don't really put out I'm
like my worst enemy dude if I don't work
out look I'm gonna gym I walk in and I
go I'm like you know what do you did a
good job it is I pat myself on the back
and I drag myself out there it's I gotta
work out myself like dude get out bro
you know for me like sometimes you know
you're lifting you lose reps and you
miss count when I missed count I have to
give myself a penalty set for a bike not
remembering my oh you wanna [ __ ] y'all
gonna forget [ __ ] I'll forget
one and I'm like it's alright I throw
the other one
I don't even forget I purposely if the
rep is ten if I hit mate I might that's
close like a what's the extra tuba to do
you know what's funny is I don't think
you're lying I'm not I'm absolutely not
dude that's why when I work out with him
I don't want him to be next to me cuz
he'll count he goes you got two more
what are you talking about I prevent
David from back in it - he's like how
many more reps you have on my [ __ ] I'm
not gonna lie to him I only did eight
but if you don't ask me I'm lying 100% I
always round down if I miss calculate
I'm always if it's supposed to be ten
I'm like oh I think and I think I did 12
or something my guys might probably be
down I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]